j'organise si le lieutenant mike horn on
a un cambriolage sur les bords
j'espérais une entité une plaque plage
c'est le type le plus rapide là dedans
tu as besoin d'un truc îles à sion
attendez études et paresseux quoi tu
veux dire que parce que c'est un
paresseux il peut pas être rapide flash
pêche rapide flèche après mon gars je
suis content de te voir à vide de devoir
aussi le temps du dialogue police
comment ça va disons que je vais bien
bien que accroche-toi puis-je faire via
j'espérais que vous puissiez vous eh
bien j'espère est aujourd'hui et bien
j'espérais que vous puissiez identifié
une plaque pour nous oui on est vraiment
super préfet quel numéro 29
tu es de la plaque
29 thd 03 22
9 thd 030 3d vers 3 0l flash je te
raconte une bien bonne
d'accord or quels mots qualifie une
chamelle à 3 me je sais pas enceinte
ah ah ah
c'est amusant très amusant ps comparé ce
consensus il a alors oui flash quels
mots galifi jamais là trois bosses au
sein ok on a compris la nouvelle
il faut éviter l'heure de pointe et ses
nuits